ils veulent apporter leur contribution à
la ryder cup
une trentaine de personnes a participé à
la matinée de recrutement de
l'entreprise clean even france une
société spécialisée dans le secteur du
nettoyage notamment pour les grands
événements sportifs
les structures sont assez bas 9 a monté
spécialement pour l'événement notre
mission à nous bat sara de maintenir les
les structures en bon état et enfin pour
l'accueil du public
donc on est rentré en contact avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et le pôle emploi afin de ba2
d'avoir un vivier humain de staff qui
habite pas loin de l'événement cette
entreprise mobilisera près de 180
personnes par jour durant la semaine de
compétition
ce matin là elle est venue recruter 150
collaborateurs en contrats pendant la
semaine de la ryder cup une chance je
sais pas c'est suivant le recrutement et
vu que l'accès pour que 4 juin d'une
geisha ça peut être bon mais ça peut
être se relancer sur un autre projet ce
vivier humain qu'on
on recrute aujourd'hui bas reste dans
notre base de données on est très très
susceptible d'être rappelé pour les
événements d'après parce que même
vis-à-vis de la région daguillon cours
qu'on garde l'open de france qui est un
événement moindre comparé à la ryder cup
mais quand même qui n'est pas cassée
considérable et qu'on utilise 80
personnes au lieu des 180 sur une ryder
cup pour les candidats retenus après
avoir rempli les documents la création
d'une accréditation est obligatoire pour
avoir accès au golf national et
contribuer à leur manière à la réussite
de la ryder cup à saint quentin en
yvelines